begin with the battle by firefighters in
seven western states
to bring nearly 50 wildfires under
control
amid extremely hot weather the two
largest in oregon and california have
forced many people
out of their homes luciano is near the
scene of another fast moving fire
threatening areas near yosemite national
park lilia good morning
good morning overnight winds have died
down
but they come and go right now as i feel
some wind i'm seeing flames spark up in
front of me
and smoldering spots like these are seen
all along the road
more than a thousand firefighters have
been actively and aggressively fighting
displays
despite working in temperatures well
above 100 degrees
and while they've made some progress
dozens of fires
raging throughout the west is a sign
that we
are on for a dangerous inactive fire
season
searing heat along with windy dry
conditions fueled the river fire monday
as it burned near yosemite national park
and raced towards homes this fire is
picking up very fast wind is changing
direction
as you can see the crews are trying to
stop the flames from jumping over
the fires are forcing people living here
to take quick action to save their lives
and their livestock rancher justin
weavers is helping move cattle
miles out of harm's way we're dealing
with the third back-to-back
heat wave what has that been like deadly
it's freaking hot
especially when you're working outside
less than 200 miles north
this video captured firefighters running
for cover
as the beckworth complex fire just north
of lake tahoe
exploded
the blaze ignited by lightning is
california's largest fire so far this
year
the strong winds continue to whip up the
flames
a big concern for bob schoenstein that
fire can be on the other side of that
mountain and put embers down in the
middle of this town and burn this down
to the ground
the fires are erupting as record
temperatures have been seen
across the west a trend experts have
attributed
to climate change unless we as a society
make drastic changes
this is better it's never going to get
cooler it's hard to
take that reality in but that's the
truth
to give you an idea of just how ripe
conditions are for wildfires in
california
2020 last year was the worst year for
wildfires in this state
now take the amount of acres that had
burnt at this time last year
multiply that by three and that's still
less than how many acres have burned so
far
this year adriana lilia thank you so
much